Can you tell me your thoughts on LDN, low dose neltruxone, would it be combined with mistletoe?
So low dose neltruxone is an off label use of the drug neltruxone.
Neltruxone is ruled that I think it was 50 milligrams or people getting off of heavy
drug drugs like morphine. Neltruxone is used to help get people off of drugs like morphine,
street drugs, people that are addicted to drugs. But that's at 50 milligrams.
Someone I don't know who it was, I don't remember the story, that found that using it
in a low, low dose, starting at 1.5 milligrams, point up to 3 milligrams, and then up to
the maximum 4.5 milligrams, it's called low dose neltruxone. So they're using it off label.
When you use a drug off label, you're using it for something that it wasn't technically approved
of by the FDA. So if it wasn't approved by the FDA for that, you're using it off label
needed for some other thing. Low dose neltruxone has been used for auto-immune diseases because
it tends to be an immune balancer or an immune regulator or what's called a T cell regulator.
It acts as stimulating what are called T-reg cells. So when a person is auto-immune and their
immune system is flared against something, with auto-immune, it's flared against self-tissue,
and then low dose neltruxone can call that down. Now, there's been some alternative doctors
that have used low dose neltruxone for cancer, which I don't know. To me, I struggle with
understanding pathways with that because it really acts like a T-regulator and you really
want to stimulate the immune system. That's the whole idea of mistletoe therapy. Mistletoe therapy
is an immune irritant. That's how it works. As an immune irritant, it's firing a hyper-immune response,
and then with that hyper-T cell stimulation, you're going to possibly kill more cancer cells.
So I don't know why you would use low dose neltruxone combined with mistletoe.
To me, it's kind of culture-productive. So I would ask the doctor, if they're prescribing this,
why they would prescribe it that way. I'm not quite sure that seems culture-productive.
Do you think there would be positive results with my breast cancer? With mistletoe, for sure,
that's possible. But low dose neltruxone, no, we have used, we've had people on low dose neltruxone
with autoimmune disease. I haven't really recommended it. Of course, I don't recommend it,
because it is a drug, but I haven't. I wouldn't really necessarily think it would be a good fit
for cancer, even though I know that they're some alternative cancer doctors that do use it. Of course,
that's not the only thing that they're using. So I'd question whether that is really the thing
that's helping the person I don't know.